à
je marque
[Musique]
il
installez-vous par avance les yeux comme
vous voulez ce sont leurs avant de
reconnaître les faits tout en train de
faire une émission là n'était pas par
les juges je voulais juste par avance
m'excuser de polluer ce programme de
j'aime beaucoup dans le mois hâtez-vous
face à la caméra la barque voit la
présentation des costumes
alors il faut que je j'annonce mois la
vache a tenté d'arrêter un tour de chant
alors on va me le dire eu des rejets à
rayer attention flamenco en fait comme
s'il n'était pas là sur un flamenco
enflammé christophe carrière et sa
partenaire emilie lopez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci et savoure également bon allez
vous asseoir leur on me dit qu'on va
donner les notes maintenant d'accord les
belges de psychomotricité cette année là
au départ c'était pas c'était un peu de
la danse et rapidement cette venue de
l'expression corporelle et ses premières
prend le temps de mettre le replay mais
vous auriez vu la scène je pense marquer
ce qu'il a vu mais attention bien vivant
sur la note finalement on a changé mais
vous donnez moi sur l'a9 on y va j'ai
découvert des nouvelles façons de bouger
pour faire changer le frisé la crise
d'épilepsie eloi camilli à emilie est
vraiment tout donné bof aussi récemment
il cherchait quelque chose j'ai pas
cherché mais il tourne alentours
tu as peur et c'est normal oui ils ont
promis qu'ils nous fera un petit quelque
chose nous en prime time et bien sûr oui
d'accord
whissell avait des gars a demandé de
danser dans la rue ils le font pour vous
un ballon mais leur métier s'il a
considéré cet avantage à main castaldi
et valérie b deux pays
attendez attendez passe caméras déjà
tout à avancer vous benjamin je vous en
prie quand on a la chance d'avoir une
petite veste en jean à cela n'empêche
pas les téléspectateurs et là là ça va
être danse avec les stars
il a été castée pour un téléfilm le
maquereau de belleville
attention vous êtes prêts moi je suis
pas à poil on danse qwise et
fonctionnels à boire aux oem et ses mots
faire mon métier est maintenant sur un
deuil ils vont fermer car c'est toujours
en flammes et benjamin castaldi et
valérie bénaïm
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pété le bouton du pantalon
la prime qui est cool c'est exactement
ce que j'ai remarqué benjamin je pense
que le pantalon était trop petite à un
moment donné vous n'arriviez pas à
serrer les gens ont une santé c'est
comme les gens parce que repreneur
serait ce que pour la note consensuelle
évidemment pas qu'on a vu qu'on écoute
série qu'elle découvre les missions à
celle ci m'a les crises pour moi il y
avait le rythme du jazz à travers toute
la danse voilà voilà
le problème c'est que le nom qu'on les a
vu danser on est en train de se demander
si ce groupe a de l'orgueil n'a fait
plutôt peur au début sa partie bien
qu'ils hassane alla quelque part après
il ya eu la clip bras japonaise la g10
est en cours d'autodéfense et d'oxydés
est-ce qu'on assiste un viol en direct
mais elle s'est bien défendu alors pour
benjamin ça va être un 3 pour rien il
faut les vivre on commence à faire jaser
route allez on va mais doit trouver
cette file vers 2 isabelle maury
[ __ ] alors là la tension alors elle
danse quand même un jury s'il vous plaît
c'est important pardon voilà soyez
indulgents elle va danser avec une
béquille mais non mais lui qui est très
excitée également alors attention tout
le monde est prêt sur une samba que je
qualifierais dans diable et gilles
verdez et isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
aulas
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais là j'ai emmené là alors la mairie
pensionnaires rapidement
oh
j'ai vécu
je sais
en fait la piscine j'avais jamais vu
d'abord dont des japonais qui sort sa
nouvelle danse la berbère c'est sur ces
nouvelles dans un mine de rien avec sa
béquille cuisse à bouchaoui
ah ouais c'est bien menti à geoffroy
palis mettre un bracelet électronique
c'est gênant parfois alors attention
c'est la dernière partie maintenant
avant que nos deux coachs ou fasse
l'honneur de danser quelque chose
jean-michel le plus dur pour vous ça va
être de rester concentré c'est ça le
gros comme quoi qu'il arrive de ne pas
consommer sur le flop des gens nous
regardent ascension confieront danse est
ce que la régie peut me le dire a très
bien fait je suis allé c'était quoi je
suis appuyé sur le bouton et je descends
lac à fermont amoros way est maintenant
sur un cheech endiablé jean michel mr et
capucine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel dommage
quel dommage de capucine n'ai pas été à
la hauteur parce que jean-michel quand
on sait que l'anglais wayne on m'attend
c'était de la prochaine session n'est
qu'un ou deux niveaux la salle une forme
d'un autre jeu truqué et ses frères de
parti
ok je vais être honnête avec vous
allez-y vous dansiez pas la même dans ce
sens
[Musique]